ORDER -- I
WON'T HAVE THE SECRETARY DO WE
DON'T OF CORMIER.
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL START
A SUBCOMMITTEE BEFORE WEEK
ESTABLISH A QUORUM --
WE ARE THREE BILLS ON FILE TODAY
AND WE'RE READY FOR THE FIRST
ONE I AM THE FIRST AUTHOR
PRESENCE THEREFORE.
I WILL GO FIRST MISTER KILEY
WILL BE OUR SHARE
.
ALRIGHT WAS.
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTEEN TAKE CARE
AND YEAH I AM [inaudible]
SEVENTY EIGHTY SEVEN SIX BACK.
SEVEN AMERICAN LEADING THE PRIOR
FROM [inaudible]
LANGUAGE FLUENTLY LAW
[inaudible]
BETTER.
RELEASED ABOUT A SINGLE PLAN.
THE REQUESTED SCHOOL BLESSED
COURTNEY.
VARIOUS STATE AND FEDERAL
FEDERAL PROGRAM FUNDS INTO A
SINGLE.
HOWEVER THE LAW GOVERNING THESE
PLANS AND LOCAL CONTROL.
WARM [inaudible]
THEIR EXISTENCE.
LEASES LOS DON'T HAVE CHANGE FOR
OUR CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS.
SAME AMERICAN CURRENCY
[inaudible]
AND THIS DOG IS A SINGLE PLAYER
--
BY DOING THE FOLLOWING.
WELL.
I DON'T REYES OBSOLETE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE DAYS. FOR
OVER AMERICANS SECOND.
FOR IT ALSO RULES THAT
[inaudible]
YOU SINGLE [inaudible] ZERO
PLANNING [inaudible]
FOR YEAH I ABILITY.
AND ALLOW SMALL AND ROOMS
[inaudible]
OPERATE.
SELECT IS EITHER [inaudible]
SHARE [inaudible]
SIZE.
THE BILL PASSED ON A VOTE OF
THIRTY SENATE IN CALIFORNIA AT
THAT PROCESS IS DONE THROUGH THE
SINGLE PLAN FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
AT THIS BILL OF LINES THEIR
SINGLE PLANNED WITH LCF HAVE.
FURTHER THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
DOING TO INTEGRATE OUR STATE
FEDERAL AND LOCAL EDUCATION
SYSTEMS AND WILL HELP REDUCE --
DUPLICATIVE PINEY REQUIREMENTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THINK YOU.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MR DOT OBJECT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I'VE OF THE MOTION IS.
I WOULD WE ACTUALLY DON'T OF A
QUORUM I'D.
ONE TWO WE NEED.
TO FOR SOME MISTER DONAHUE LIKE
TO RETURN TO THE DYESS --
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
ANY OTHER AUTHORS PRESENT EITHER
[inaudible]
BOB.
IT THAT.
THE SECRETARY COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY HERE KILEY HERE KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER HERE WE HAVE
.
AFTER ABOUT A YEAH SO I MAY GO
AHEAD AND CALL [inaudible]
I'M.
BUT PROTECT GOOD.
BOB THE ONLY REMAINING AUTHORED
BE CALLED WOULD BE MR MCCARTY.
HE'S GOT THREE MINUTES --
COULD WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
AB SEVEN SIXTEEN BY O'DONNELL.
THE MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SECOND.
I MOVED AND SECONDED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL I AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY STEINORTH
STEINORTH AYE THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS FIVE VOTED US OUT
WHEN WE TAKE UP THE YET THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS --
AB SCR ONE SIX SEVEN BY MISTER
PORTANTINO. ONE FIVE SEVEN SORRY
--
THE MOTION IS.
BEAT TO BE ADOPTED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO BE
ADOPTED.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE PARTY.
STEINORTH STEINORTH FINE I
THURMOND.
THURMOND DIED WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I WILL HAS SIX WAS IT IS
HOUR WAITING FOR MR MCCARTY HIS
STAFF IS LISTENING I RECOMMEND
HE HAD THIS WAY.
OR WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN
[inaudible]
WHAT TYPE [inaudible]
IF.
IF YOU'VE GOT THE STATE MANNER
ME RIGHT.
IT WAS JUST PART OF A PLANNER.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE MR MCCARTY IS
ON THIS COMMITTEE EVERY ELSE
HERE.
THANK YOU SO CHAIR MEMBERS --
PROUD THE PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
MYSELF OF THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH NEW METRICS IN OUR
ADULT EDUCATION SYSTEM HELP US
DETERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS.
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY ARE DULL EDUCATION
SYSTEM USES TWO MEASURES OF
SUCCESS FOR IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE STUDENTS CONTINUED
EDUCATION AND JOINING THE WORK
FORCE IT DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THE
PROGRESS.
THAT IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
STUDENTS MAKE.
IN TERMS OF INTEGRATING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL WOULD
ACCOUNT PLEASE IMPORTANT
MILESTONES IN BETTER INFORM US.
ABOUT HOW OUR ADULT EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS WORKING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL WITNESS THANK YOU THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
NEW A PRISSY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST ON KEPT KEY WITH
MCCUE CAPTAINED ASSOCIATES HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION.
ARE BOTH CO SPONSORS OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION NOW WE
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ACCOUNTING FOR
OUTCOMES AND PROGRESS OF ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS IN THE SUCCESS.
OF THAT OUR ADULT SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER THE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM ARE
HAVING IN TERMS OF WORKING WITH
THIS POPULATION.
THINK THIS IS A VERY POSITIVE
I'M BILL I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PARRIS I'M CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WE'VE WORKED WITH THE
SPONSORS --
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR
WHEN I WAS A BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
WE CONTINUE TO BE IN SUPPORT HOW
WE DO KNOW THAT THE BILL HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED TO
ADDRESS COSTS.
AND WE DO ASK THAT IMMIGRANT
ADVOCATES BE A PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS UP AS
EQUAL PARTNERS TO THE ADULT
ADULT EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
AS FOUR INPUTS AS DALY WITH
THESE COMMUNITIES AND COMPOUND
FIGHT INSIGHT AND EXPERIENCE
ABOUT WHAT MAKES A SUCCESSFUL
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
WITH THAT --
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION SING OPPOSITION TO
ANY ANY.
CONFIRMATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THAT'S A GREAT BILL THINK.
SO I YOU KNOW OUR ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL
CALIFORNIA AND THEY ALMOST FACE
THE DEATH PENALTY DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION SERVING SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS AND ARE YOU
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND WE
ATTEMPTED --
TO RE PRIORITIZE THEM IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE HAVE AND THAT
THIS WILL.
ENABLE US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
AND THEN DEVELOP --
PROGRAMS AS FAR AS WHERE WE'RE
AT WE'RE READY TO GO SO --
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THIS BILL
MISTER THERE NO THANK YOUS
MCCARTY.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY I
TAUGHT ADULT DETERMINE YEARS AT
NIGHT.
SO I AND WELL UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE PART OF PEOPLE ACHIEVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM SO THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND AND MOVED AND SECONDED
AYE THE MOTION IS.
OCCUR AND TO PASS TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL I
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMOND AYE THURMOND AYE
WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL'S OUT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
BOB.
ON THE OTHER END OF THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED